last year you celebrated 125 years
consetta
orchestra um in your response to what
has been said maybe you can include a
few comments on it has there been any
change in the in the in the meaning of
the concept about 20 125 years ago and
now or do you think that this building
is still having the same function in our
society as it had used to have hundred
years ago as society has changed and is
still changing our role is changing too
I'm afraid it's such a big topic to talk
about you know I don't think we need to
convince yourself of the relevance of
culture and the relevance of this
beautiful hall and all the orchestra's
and musicians and ensembles that play
here day in day out that's not the
central question and I think we should
try to avoid to become a sort of group
and maybe it's a bit too ruled but to
avoid that we become a sort of group of
grumpy old man complaining about that
culture is important and that the rest
is foolish that will not help us I think
I'm a positive guy by nature fortunately
and I think optimism is an obligation
that might help us because I'm convinced
deeply convinced that especially the
role of music in our society is
extremely important and music is in
every single individual present maybe
some exceptions such as the wolf kid as
you explained after 12 years old but
from the very first day that a kid is
alive it can recognize rhythm and melody
and whatsoever it's there I think we
should concentrate upon the question
what we can do to give access to all
those children of our society we are
extremely extremely privileged people in
this hall and especially around the
table we have we have wonderful
education some their own education but
nevertheless
intelligent people we love art we know
art we make art we are working in the
world of art in several roles so we
don't need to convince ourselves but we
should realize that there is a huge
majority outside this group whereas just
simply no clue of us let alone the role
of arts and the necessity of arts and my
question is what can we and what should
we do to give all this this huge
majority access to the arts and how can
we support those kids to get along to
know arts and very important how can we
foster concentration because in the
world of this multimedia and all those
smartphones are whatsoever it's so
difficult to learn kids to focus to
concentrate to develop their own
thoughts so there is a lot of sight wind
also so they don't know the arts and
there's a lot of sight with the dead
culmination is quite a disaster I think
and as we used to say in the Netherlands
you can better fly flees with syrup
rather than with a whip I think the
support of this institution that's your
question of the no love all those
musicians and ensembles and officers
that play a day in day out of our
society the support of the society is
extremely important and that's the
reason why we recently launched a new
initiative or we call the digital
learning line one of the tragedies of
our education system is that over the
last 20 30 years lesson as kids have
music education in the class they don't
have it because teachers are afraid to
give music lessons they shamed the cells
because they cannot sing or they simply
have no background in music so they
simply cannot give you the music
education so we try to convert that and
we came up with the idea to work with
the publisher with education publisher
to bring the music lessons back into the
classes and our initiative is a digital
learning line that enables all those
teachers in the classes do you give
music lessons one hour per week at least
one hour per week during eight years so
at least the kids get along with it they
know what music is about and hopefully
there will enable the the teachers to
give music lessons in the future so you
know it's not ignorance that it's a
problem because in a human being that as
ignorant is proud that he doesn't know
those kids just don't simply they simply
do not know about me it's because they
don't recognize it and I'm so convinced
that as I told the beginning music is in
every single kid but we have to enable
them to get have the axis of this music
and to support them in a proper way I
think that's it and it's a very
practical approach because the situation
is in my view really terrible it's a
sort of desert outside there are so few
kids so few people that know what we do
here in this institution and as long and
as soon as they get here they become
more fans and what that's the work we
try to do day in day out it's my very
short story